today we're gonna discuss some of the
biggest outstanding mysteries in my ear'
academia and to do this today I have one
of my fellow favorite my hair Kadima
youtubers with me now he and I have
collab before in his channel and it
would be amazing if you guys would
subscribe to him and check him out his
channel is called my hero my life how
you doing man ah dude I'm doing great
thanks for having me man I really
appreciate it
no problem man but before we get into a
massive spoiler warning to anyone
reading or anyone watching sorry who's
not read the manga as we're going to be
going into like some of the most recent
arcs and things that have happened so
the first mystery that I wanted to talk
to you about in terms of the future of
like the quark destroying and quark
restoring bullets I mean we saw in the
overhaul talk recently that you know
sugar Aki stole a bunch of them so what
do you think is the future of these
bullets like are they gonna be used in
the upcoming war do you think no exactly
there's an exact that's a perfect moment
for him to to use them and use those on
heroes whether it's just a whole group
of people have a bunch of guns with them
or even imagine one person with a
machine gun
chucked full of these bullets like that
would just be super crazy right I've
never even thought about that imagine
that a machine gun full of like quite
destroying forests I have Devon that
should be illegal that should be right
right I mean imagine hunt you know
hundreds of pro heroes coming at you and
all you have is this machine gun you
know taking them all out you know and
there you go like hundreds of heroes no
longer have quirks literally gone
forever or until they get their quirk
back because honestly my theory is and
we can if we want to get to this later
but my theory is that miryo will
definitely get his quirk back I think
that the way Ares quirk works is it more
rewinds things and so it just takes time
to get back up to speed to when you
actually had your quirk another thing I
had is this is completely in a different
direction but if the police could ever
get their hands on the quirk destroying
stuff I actually don't think it'd be a
bad idea maybe not to the degree where
it actually destroys the quirk but there
were bullets prior to this that showed
them take quirks away for a
moment in time and so I actually think
it'd be great the police could get their
hands on and they start to use this to
kind of stop villains specifically to be
able to arrest them and things like that
yeah because like you said those are the
prototype versions right the ones that
we zoom like Tamaki and was easing
anyone else I think it was just Tamaki
actually did was used yeah I think I
think it's what we saw it on exactly
yeah that would be really interesting
cuz like you could take out for example
I mean we're gonna get to in a second
but sugar Aki with his new power we have
like no idea what's gonna be but we know
it's gonna be insane you could just like
hit him with one of the bullets and then
one here just comes in and gets him in
the face knocks him out of something
that could be that could that could work
right but yeah we may as well move on to
that so obviously in the latest chapter
we saw sugar Aki in that table light
sort of like Darth Vader or something
and recovering from whatever dr. Hugo
did to him um so what do you think like
realistically will be the extent of his
new power especially given that we know
that the doctor can replicate quarks now
yeah well I actually feel like this is
somewhat of a comparison to when Deku
was preparing and training his body to
receive the quark from Almighty and so I
kind of feel like that is what's going
on with sugar rocky right now is that
they're preparing him and maybe they're
giving him an ability but they're
specifically he's going through a
training a metamorphosis whatever you
want to call it a change so that he will
be ready to get the quark from all-4-one
because I don't think this is the quark
itself I don't think he's getting that
but obviously he is a successor so he
needs to get it sooner or later and so I
think he's preparing his body and I
think like a typical anime sooner or
later like shigga Rocky's going to have
a new form because almost every anime
bad guy like they change forms I mean
even overhaul he uses quark to look
different by the end of it with the
fight with Deku and so I imagine him
coming out and being able to do
something I don't have specifics but it
will you know specifically make them
look different however the whole purpose
of this is get them closer to being
ready for all for once
work yeah yeah not for sure I mean yeah
like you say he is the successor so it's
almost inevitable that he will get all
for one in some way what I was thinking
of though is that his original dick a
quark like we saw in the Milan academia
arc how it evolved so that the things he
touched like he was decaying things that
he wasn't even touching anymore it was
like things that had connected to things
he's touching so one of the things that
I was thinking is that after this whole
process is over is it possible that he
could decay things that he doesn't even
touch at all so for example he sticks
his hand out and suddenly like people
just start evaporating he's not even
touched to me wow just wow that would be
yeah that's one of the things I mean if
that was the case you can't even get
near him right yeah so you think he's
going more through like an evolution
like his quark is getting taken to the
next level I think so because just
before he went in for that operation I
remember he was the doctor was like oh
your quarks finally awakened and then
sugar ah he was like yeah but look at my
hand like it's still been destroyed
after I uh after what I did so I think
like when he comes out his his base
decay quark will 100% be better just
because of the way he was complaining
about how his body reacted but yeah like
you say they're obviously gearing up to
take all for one as well there's no
question about that but this whole and
going going sorry and going back to that
I really do want to stress and I don't
know why I feel like this is a big deal
but I really do think that that out of
this he will get some sort of new form
and maybe it even plays into what you
were just saying you know specifically
with his quark maybe I'll have almost
like this decay form where he just he
looks different he's again I just think
this is something that is a very common
trope in anime yeah I mean that is a
good point because do you remember that
panel like just before he went in and it
was like him inside a cocoon it was just
like a right exactly yeah
meta mean you know metamorphosis there's
something changing he is going to look
different or at least be able to have an
ability to look different I don't think
he'll look you know different all the
time but I think he'll be just something
that a new transformation that he may be
able to choose to to do when he's
someone that's a big deal yeah I mean I
mean to be honest we might even see it
sooner than we think cause I mean the
heroes you know they're storming the
hospital suga Rocky is literally right
there I mean what if his what if he like
here's what's going on and suddenly his
his like the glass around him starts to
crack or something and he just escapes
and starts killing all the bro heroes
right what that means right yeah I mean
it would be a bit early because you know
he still has like another month to go
but I mean that could happen put
potentially but I'm moving on from sugar
Aki now so we've spoken about what his
potential upgrades might look like
bought about deku so we know that Dec
who's gonna get this float power from
Nana shamora but in terms of the other
quacks quacks that are inside one for
all I remember back ago said that it
would they weren't that great but what
do you think what could they possibly be
yeah so when I was thinking about it and
specifically these quirks so we know
he's going to get float which is you
know similar to flying at least it will
look like he's gonna be able to have
battles in the sky to some degree which
is very similar to like Superman and
other heroes like that and then he's
gotten the black whips which to me is
similar to Spider Man I feel like these
quirks that he's getting are actually my
hero academia versions a very you know
popular Western superhero quirks and so
you know as I thought about it you know
what if he control lightning like for
what if he could you know create shields
and be able throw them at Captain
America there's so many different
options available when you go that route
however however with that being said I
wouldn't say that the character designs
that we've seen really fit any of those
ideas that I just threw out there so I
made kind of a different you know note
of things as I look at those guys and
look at the way that they're designed I
think of different quirks so I was think
about the guy that has like the would
you call it like a long coat trench coat
it almost looks like like best genus and
as I was thinking about his quirk you
know I sort of asked myself like why are
you wearing this coat like what's that
what's the need for it
I thought what if inside of this huge
coat are all these compartments right
and so in each compartment has all these
different things what if he can control
things with his mind right and so he has
on him all these support items in order
to save people in order to battle in
order to whatever is needed at that
moment and so it's not like oh man right
now I could use a hammer so I need to
look around the room to see if I can
find a hammer and know I have one on me
because whenever I need a hammer I will
use it and not that I was like oh I have
to grab it I just use my mind and if you
even go back to what I just said with
hey what if these powers were kind of
similar to Western comics there are
plenty of characters that use their
minds when it comes at you know items
what I think you call that like a
telepath or something similar to that
kind of Kinesis or something telekinesis
there you go right so what if he was
just simply telekinetic and you know I
was even thinking about if you look at
the picture I think it was the first
time he's he's shown it looks like he
has bandages on his arms and that
reminded me of the material that
Eraserhead uses to capture villains like
and that goes back to this idea that he
has all these different support items
that he uses with his mind so that was
my thought for him and that would then
give of course dr. telekinesis as we
were just saying and then finally the
other guy would like the scars on his
like on his face Oh about that yeah so I
was thinking about him and I was like
what if that's not a scar like what if
that's a mark like what if it says curse
smart and so whenever he touches someone
write that mark leaves him goes through
his his you know goes down his face down
his arm and on to the individual and now
that individual is cursed for X amount
of time he can still do everything
normal but then sooner or later that
curse will get him and he'll be
completely disabled and just shut down
and then he puts his hand back on the
guy and the curse mark goes back onto
him so he can transfer that to someone
else
later when he's fighting
be a very interesting and unique quirk
yeah that quote would be kind of like
supernatural in a way wouldn't it it
sounds kind of yeah kind of which is we
haven't seen too much of that I'd say in
this world and it would be a fun way to
see more of it yeah for sure man I mean
I really like that idea of them being
like tied to Western superhero type
powers because often what I find is that
Western superior type powers are very
simple if you know what I mean like for
example I mean Superman like he can fly
he can you know he's strong stuff like
that
so it does make sense because the
earlier back you go into like the
evolution of quirks the simpler they are
so it would make sense they would be
kind of like like American superhero
powers yeah really good point man yeah
so moving on let's go to deck who's dr.
potentially being well not potentially I
mean we basically know he's the same guy
yeah unless he has a twin brother yeah
yeah but like 1% now but yeah right why
do you think horikoshi made this
connection like why have the evil doctor
who's harvesting all these quarks and
who has you know all these no more his
disposal why make him deck whose
childhood doctor what was the reason for
that well you know I've heard this
before some people think that deku used
to have a quirk and then maybe the
doctor was able to take it from him and
later this will be a big reveal that you
know deku always had a quirk so that's a
really good you know way of looking at
it I think another way you could just
say is here Koji just got lazy but I
doubt that I very much doubt that
because he really does put a lot of work
and effort in this so with that being
said I do think there has to be a reason
do I know the reason well there's no way
I could but that's why I do like the
idea that maybe Deku originally had a
quirk and he just stole it in the moment
of when he was giving Deku his exam for
lack of better terms yeah or the other
possibility horikoshi is just trolling
everyone by doing this and he needed a
design for the evil doctor looks like
you know what maybe I should just make
Dec who's doc to this evil guy
yeah yeah maybe but um yeah I mean I do
I do kind of like that theory that he
did ever quark that was stolen but at
the same time I'm like I don't know
because the whole thing about Deku was
that you know he's this naturally born
quark this kid and then this amazing
thing happens to him he gets given his
power so let's say that the doc let's
say he did have a quark and that the
doctor you know never did this crazy
thing that kind of changed that would
have changed the whole trajectory of the
show like the deck who we know was quark
with Deku he will he worked so hard
because he was quite classy he took all
those nights about all those heroes
because he was like oh one day I'm gonna
get my quark so I should take all these
know and I'm like exactly from the get
would he be the same person I don't know
I don't think so no not at all no it
would completely change everything but
then it also could play into the ideas
that you know all for one is really
behind everything and he's this even
bigger mastermind than what he already
seems like what if he wanted Deku to get
his you know to get one for all like
what if that was his plan
I think I'd mentioned this before when
you and I had collabed in a different
video I truly do believe that it's going
to be revealed sometime that all for one
is Dec whose dad and I know that can
seem a little weird because they talk
about what Dec whose dad's quark was and
that doesn't really fit up with it but
just knowing that Kirikou she loves Star
Wars and we know that Darth Vader is Oh
spoiler warning Darth Vader is Luke
Skywalker dad you know I just know that
would I just think that would fit well
and that would play into more of how
this whole thing had been orchestrated
yeah yeah no I I don't buy into that
theory but I do see the comparison like
the stall was comparison is very obvious
I mean what all-4-one his design is
almost like quite similar to Darth Vader
isn't it like the helmet and the way
that is right right and I can't I can't
see the Star Wars connection for sure
but I actually feel it would be kind of
cheap if he was dec whose dad especially
when you considered the fact that all
the one we know he's aware of deku cuz
when he was fighting all my you know he
said he said to all my like is
midoriya like that's what you gave it to
right so mm-hmm if he if he knew that
was his son it would have been a good
moment then to have said something right
like he'd be like that's my son like you
just gave it too much I don't know I
don't know I've I wouldn't like it but
at the same time like if it was to
happen I couldn't be like oh this is out
of nowhere cuz cuz there is obvious
signs there with you know the doctor and
right right and the Star Wars connection
yeah I'm not saying it's the best thing
I'm not even saying that I like it I'm
just saying I it wouldn't surprise me
I'm actually playing I'm I'm waiting for
it like I'm expecting it for sure
alright every chapter you just like is
this the Lord is this the time alright
so on to the next topic
what do you think Hawkes his true
loyalties are here cuz I mean we've seen
over the last few chapters you know he
was the one who led the heroes to the
hospital where they've been you know
attacked by all these nomu do you think
that maybe he's turned into a bit of a
triple agent and that he's working
against the heroes what do you think no
he's still a good guy well I like to
believe that he is a good guy but that's
what the Hmong is making us believe and
so how crazy would it be that there's
this twist that he's actually a bad guy
and the best way to really make this
twist happen is that some hero that we
already care and love about he literally
stabs in the back and kills in front of
all of us that would be a big shock
especially if it's a way for him to
prove himself to other villains that he
really is a part of this paranormal
Liberation Front and so I just really
think that'd be cool
I don't know if it's true you know that
he's actually on their side but I kind
of would like him to be a bad guy to be
honest yeah I mean he's been into it
integrated with them for a while now
like it's possible that he went in there
with good intentions and now he's been
integrated for so long that he's
starting to believe it I mean because we
did see with twice like him and twice do
have a genuine friendship I don't I
personally don't think that's fake I
think they do actually like each other
what do you think about that yeah I you
know I don't know I mean that's a really
good point and that that could actually
be his entry point into being on the
dark side
you know to enter into that in just but
you know maybe I do actually like what
they're saying more than you know this
world of pro heroes hmm yeah because I
mean we know hooks the philosophy it's
all about freedom right he just wants to
live a chill life not too much crime and
so like the whole point of like the
paranormal Liberation Front is to
liberate society you where you know
everyone can essentially use their
quirks and there isn't such a thing as a
pro hero really because everyone can use
their quirks so I think in a way you
could see how his ideology would line up
with them right right right exactly 100%
I mean what do you think do you think
he's actually a bad guy or do you think
guy not at this moment I do actually
think he's a good guy like at heart I do
actually think he has the potential to
be turn though just based on like the
things I just said in terms of his
philosophy I guess it all comes down to
how successful this next chat I mean
this next like storyline is so the hair
is all getting a tight if they're all
defeated what does he do he can't he
can't take home the whole army by
himself canny so if the heroes are
defeated he might not have any choice
but to stay with the paranormal
aberration front and keep pretending to
be a bad guy and you know who knows
maybe eventually he will actually become
one but yeah if heroes are defeated
there's nowhere for him to turn to
because he can't just leave like he's
easy deep right right right yeah exactly
exactly no that's good that's good and
so that kind of leads me into the next
question so one one big mystery the
people of respecting about speculating
about for a long time is Hawkes is fate
so like I said he's in deep will the
heroes if they succeed will they punish
him for killing best genius if indeed
he's done that or do you think if the
villain succeeds will they kill him for
you know betraying them or does he get
out clean like no one no one finds out
about what he's done yeah well I mean if
he's you know if he is a still good guy
and gets caught he's gonna get turned
into a no moon for sure one percent just
expect that um if if he's a bad guy I
think we're gonna see him do some heavy
damage to to the heroes but I think in
the end run they'll get their justice
and Hawkes will be eliminated arrested
whatever you want to put it it's going
to happen to him so
but it's hard because we really don't
know is he what side is he really on hmm
and this bring me to another question
actually so let's say in in an ideal
world the heroes win right Hawks
if if if the heroes win would it be
right for Hawks to go to jail for
killing best genius like let's imagine
an ideal world they win and they find
out he killed him at the end of the day
he was given this task by the government
to infiltrate the league of villains and
you know do whatever was necessary so do
you think he deserves to go to jail you
know that is so hard because I mean
obviously I'm not a double agent but if
I was a double I hate it you know what
would it take to really prove your
loyalty to be able to get in you know
and I feel like in some instances things
just have to be forgiven because you're
just doing your job
yeah and that's sad
but possibly very true so no I think
that he should be forgiven mmm yeah I
mean once endeavour once endeavour finds
out about that he's not let any of
course get off easy hi I don't care how
good friends they are endeavours gonna
be the crap out of him if he finds out
right right right but but on the topic
of like endeavour and the Totoro keys
obviously this theories been going
around I think for years but yeah
forever from the moment he showed up
honest honestly man do you think Dobby
is Endeavor son who's Toyota Dorothy
yeah I don't think there's any way that
he can be the problem is is that it is
yet to be stated and Dobby has been
around
Todoroki he's been around endeavour on
at least one or two occasions and no one
from either party has said anything to
each other or behind closed doors and so
that means that if Dobby is Toya then
there had been something that happened
to him some sort of changing and so I
have this idea that Toya actually did
die maybe and ever took things too far
and you know endeavour basically abused
his child to death whatever but either
way
toya died that is my thought process and
maybe someone had a quirk that brought
people back from the dead and but maybe
there were certain aspects to that would
make Toya look a little bit different
and more specifically that Toya would
not have those memories from his past
life and so Dobby literally started from
the moment that Toya was brought back to
life and so this is all things that
would have to be revealed later on when
they started you know exploring Dhabi's
past but yeah I really do think that
that that would be that and that also
explains some of the stitches some of
those different aspects to go along with
that but I don't think it can be just as
simple as oh yeah that's Toya there has
to be more because why is nobody talking
about this yeah I mean well you do you
just kind of mentioned just there but
endeavour does think that Toya is dead
right like you never admitted to that
show yeah so at least he thinks that
happened so you might be right in that
aspect the one thing that I would
disagree with you a bit on though I do
think that they have spoken about it
because like if you remember when I
think I was doing the pro-hero arc Dobby
approached endeavour right and so there
were two things one it's very convenient
that endeavour couldn't see properly in
that scene I think his eyes were like
blurry is all I can't see properly and
they're obviously Dobby standing right
in front of him and if that is his son
then clearly he'd recognize him in
normal circumstances so I found it weird
the horikoshi specifically was like
endeavour can't see properly in the
scene that was the first like red flag
the second one was that Dobby was like
to him we needed to have a chat
basically he was like now that I've got
you me to talk endeavour and then Mirko
shows up out of nowhere and kind of just
like cost that conversation short but I
feel like if he was reborn in the way
that you said and didn't remember things
I feel like he probably wouldn't have
had any reason to have a chat with
endeavour specifically and I think one
of the other things that people have
mentioned is that whenever he's
interacted with Todoroki you know Shoto
or or endeavour he's always called them
by their full names he's always had like
shutter Todoroki or ng whereas with
other characters doesn't really do that
so I feel like Dobby himself that bee
knows and he's just waiting for the
right moment
to drop this bombshell on them
potentially when he's about to kill them
you know when he thinks he's about to
kill them anyway yeah I don't know I
don't know what do you think but again
you know I mean like in the the the
forest training arc or whatever when
dobby takes Baca go you know Todoroki
was there he saw him and again like that
should have initiated something inside
him like whoa this dude looks like my
brother like my brother had died what
how is he still alive but yet nothing
came out of that and that's where it
really pushes me to fake that that he
there has to be something going on there
and maybe maybe Dobby does remember
things maybe he does remember his past
life or maybe the reason why he wants to
talk to endeavour is because he himself
is seeing the similarities he himself is
like man I got these like these these
memories that I can't totally piece
together and I'm trying to figure out
who I am but why are you in my memories
endeavor why are you there like I need
to know what's going on because I'm
trying to piece some things together and
this makes no sense
but maybe I'm over complicating it no no
maybe not I mean what the one thing I
would say about Shoto though is that
obviously we know his childhood was so
traumatic he was almost like segregated
from his brothers and sisters wasn't he
like me to train by himself wasn't they
were able to play just it's possible
that maybe he wouldn't recognize Dobby
if it was if it was Toya especially
without all the scars and the fact that
he's grown up since then I don't know I
mean it's possible I mean whenever this
is revealed I mean has to be revealed
sometime soon I hope within the next
year at least cuz we've been waiting so
long right right right yeah we just need
this story especially like we got the
backstory of you know a lot of the
villains you know toga twice Shigure aki
like people were waiting for Dobby to to
be revealed and it just never came so
I'm hoping that it happens in this walk
but um just before we like round out the
video do you have any expectations for
this art that's going on in the manga
right now like in terms of you know
maybe a hero gets hit with the quote
destroying bullet or something crazy
like that do you have any expectations
for what's about to happen uh well I
typically read it with no expectation
I'm just excited however um I really
would like to see honestly I like the
villains to win I would like the whole
world to get flipped upside down and
that essentially deku second year never
can really happen because everything
gets flipped upside down and he's so
busy trying to deal with what is going
on because with that shift I would
imagine that schools like you a would be
ill you know irrelevant because you
don't need a hero license anymore
because the paranormal Liberation Front
has changed all that they've changed the
rules of the game and I would even argue
that with shag rocky being the head of
that the dekhta would be on the run so
that's what I would like to see I don't
think it's realistic I don't think it's
gonna happen
I think the hero's a win yay but I
always love when villains win and hero
die because it's just unrealistic
because everybody loves a good ending
yeah I wouldn't be too sure about you
know that the heroes being able to win
there because right now those higher
numbers that's high and low moves though
by actually freaks of nature right if if
you took the numbers out of the equation
I would actually give the hero such a
good chance but it's just the fact that
this they have multiple quirks imagine
just having like they're basically like
mini all4 ones they have all these
different works they're super powerful
and yeah and I'm the higher one
specifically they have intelligence as
well so yeah even though even though
it's expected that eventually the heroes
will win right now I'm I'm actually kind
of in the ballpark of yeah the villains
are gonna win deck who's gonna he's not
going back to school anytime soon it's
gonna need to like own this massive
potentially you know all my did going to
America and my training there mmm yeah
do you think I could maybe do something
like that well but I think all might was
already in college at that point I saw
it yeah so he grad oh my graduated but I
mean that wasn't this is kind of a
different circumstance in that you know
there's a like a woman right so you
might you might you might have to leave
bad idea that'd be cool to be a really
nice way to introduce some new you know
a new school a new cast of characters
you know especially if it's just him and
a few others go with him
because I don't think the whole school
could be at the same place he is that
that's an interesting take I'd like to
see that that'd be cool yeah well thanks
for coming on the channel today man I
really appreciate it
oh yeah definitely man dude anytime this
is fun a lot of people might not know
this but you were literally like one of
the first people to find my channel I
remember you like comment on one of my
videos when I had like less than 20 subs
I don't even know how you thought I
would imagine that it was with what was
his name is it reca tree Z is that a guy
oh yeah yeah you know him yeah probies I
think I found him first and I don't know
if you're connected with him at all but
I probably found you through that but
either way yeah man I just remember you
posting in and then you took some some
time to get to your next one and I was
just trying to give you a little bit of
encouragement keep going man you got
this and the next thing you know you're
like just on fire like you're literally
lit bro you're just going place I love
it I'm proud of you dude you're doing
great now thank you so much man listen
to all my subscribers watching this
right now I'd really appreciate it if
you check out my hair on my last channel
he makes awesome videos especially what
if videos as well like I really like
your what-if videos and in fact we did
one too we did want to get we did yeah
yeah you should definitely link that
guys go check out that video it was we
did that a long time ago though didn't
we yeah I was like November but yeah the
link to that video will be on screen
right now thanks for watching guys peace
out